well I think you have to be aware of
regulation as you get larger and you
don't want to make a mistake of fighting
the government and ignoring the
government so I think what Facebook is
done for example which is add a lot of
costs and a lot of people to try to get
rid of the fake news and get rid of the
bad things on the site is the way to to
to actually keep your business thriving
Google and Amazon responded to this
rather belatedly have they woken up to
this threat rather too late in the day
well I don't think it's too late but I
think maybe Google underestimated the
intensity of of the reaction the other
concerns a lot of investors have had
about tech lately is the the sheer
amount of money that's been plowed by
venture capital into startups are you
surprised we haven't seen more of these
so-called unicorns crashing and burning
well I think they're still living in
this world where there's too much
capital and people willing to pay higher
valuations for the next round that's tax
hit a number of record highs this year
what point do we start to worry whether
valuations are justified well you know
we look a lot of valuations because you
know we live through 2000 and we
understand you know Therese don't grow
to the sky so to speak but I think that
valuations are still quite reasonable in
tech tech as a universe sells just a
little bit over I think about a 3%
premium to the market multiple so we can
talk about overall valuations maybe
they're a little bit high depending on
your interest rate scenario but tech
relative to the rest of the market is
still pretty reasonable stunning see M&A
across the sector we've just had this
bid for Qualcomm from Broadcom what did
you make of that I mean so stupendous
sum of money hundred and six billion
dollars well we you know it's I guess if
your stock goes a little enough then you
know numbers big enough no numbers too
big there's plenty of money around if
you can make the economics work I think
there'll be more M&A in the tech sector
I do I think particularly if you get
this tax out past and you get this
repatriation of
sure cash you have almost a trillion
dollars of offshore cash by tech
companies that'll be brought back to the
US and I think some of that will be used
for M&A three courses of your portfolio
is in US tech stocks what do you see
what are the stories from elsewhere
around the world that catch your eye
well we're we're big fans of some of the
Asia tech companies we have a position
in Samsung Alibaba $0.10 we think those
are really great companies that are
undervalued nothing in Europe we own a
few companies in Europe we've had good
luck with a company called Sophists in
the UK that we like and Infineon as a
company that we're very high on because
of its participation in electric cars so
we think there's some there's some good
stocks to own in Europe too and one of
you made her the whole Bitcoin
phenomenon I mean the thing has fallen
by 29 percent since last Wednesday and
then rallied again very sharply over the
last 24 hours or so honestly and I don't
know what to make a bit